all right let's do the final Friday
mailbag of 2022 I know we are turning a
corner that in 2023 the emails I get
will be positive constructive not
anti-semitic who am I kidding we know
that that's not going to change it
probably will get worse all right let's
get a mix of things that came in
remember info davidpackman.com is where
you can email we will also sometimes
feature a message from Facebook or maybe
something that comes in on the YouTube
channel or whatever the case may be I
heard from a gentleman and you be the
judge as to whether they really are a
gentleman who said to us on Facebook you
are stupid Fox News is number one for a
reason that's true I don't know that we
would agree on what that reason is but
okay Fox News is number one for a reason
I bread Punk your y o u r a pace of s
your a pace and wrong you're of course
going on to say you voted for by Dawn
b-i-d-o-n that's enough to prove your
capital s stupid
f u Jesus is coming for you send you
into Bernie lava cross Jesus
so this is a commentary about a
disagreement this person has with me
over Economic Policy as I'm sure you can
tell very productive very actionable and
very much welcoming debate rather than
shutting it down extremely important
Dwayne also wrote to me and I'm going to
be careful with my pronunciation here
Wayne wrote To Me fuke you are pronouns
now this Dwayne said your y o u
apostrophe re
two emails in a row first guy uses the
wrong your Dwayne also uses the wrong
wrong you're saying I am pronouns
apparently
fuke your pronouns you never did answer
when I asked is psychology damage for a
girl like your daughter to see a boy in
a dress
it clearly is to me
to a dumb Progressive I don't know
I'm doing I'm struggling endless and God
I know English is my second language
maybe it's my my language limitation
that makes it difficult to understand
this I think what Dwayne is asking is is
it psychologically damaging for a girl
like my daughter to see a boy in a dress
you know I think you could show my
daughter just about any clothing item on
anyone
and she wouldn't care she doesn't know
what's going on that I can tell you
um no Dwayne has real problems and of
course [ __ ] you are pronouns
it could be the name of a band quite
frankly fuke you are pronouns and I
would encourage a band uh to pick up
that name but Wayne continuing not to
contribute productively to the
conversation Jen wrote in about Kerry
Lake's election trial which fortunately
has concluded with the lawsuit in the
trash which is where it should be Jen
wrote quote hi David huge fan of your
show I just moved to the Phoenix area
from Sacramento California a local news
channel here is doing a live stream of
the Kerry Lake election trial is what
they're calling it my question to you is
what is this trial going to solve or
uncover well it'll solve nothing and it
will uncover no wrongdoing and that's
exactly what happened Jen continues it
doesn't seem helpful in restoring trust
in the election that's not what it's for
the Maga crowd will say the election was
stolen if Lake isn't governor and of
course Hobbes will be the next governor
of Arizona I'd love your thoughts on
this yeah Jennifer is completely right
which is of course the trial didn't
overturn the election in results because
there's no evidence to suggest the
results should be overturned so
absolutely the trumpists will argue as
they are
that the trial itself was corrupt
and so even though now there's been a
trial and the judge said you haven't
actually provided evidence of a stolen
election so we're going to dismiss this
now it is that decision that is biased
and the court that is biased and um it's
uh this is what we call unending
skepticism skepticism is good
healthy skepticism is good hey we should
be satisfied that elections were handled
properly oh there are claims from
Arizona Let's explore the claims none of
the voting machines worked okay truth is
a few tabulators briefly didn't work
even the RNC has been satisfied that the
election was not rigged all right so the
tabulator thing probably isn't good well
people weren't allowed to vote you look
at the affidavits the affidavits say
people who showed up after the polls
close weren't allowed to vote oh well
that's the law if you show up after the
polls close if you're not in line at the
time the polls close you're not allowed
to vote that so we were skeptical
we evaluated the claims there's no
evidence for them we now move on the
unending skepticism is how conspiracy
theorists end up in a rabbit hole out of
which they cannot get and that's exactly
uh what we saw in Arizona
Peter wrote in and said why the career
change why did you go from being a
English teacher I guess Peter maybe
should have been in my class A English
teacher to a political hack now of
course
I I was never an English teacher maybe
Peter has me confused
with some other host I don't I don't
know
um but there's a lot of people in my
audience
painfully confused about what is
happening on this show Brian wrote in
about gun deaths and said David in
discussing the subject of guns and child
deaths you mentioned the instances when
someone says limiting clip capacity
wouldn't have made a difference in this
specific incident
tell them no maybe not but it might make
a difference in the next one yeah this
is a good point you know as I've said
before I have put forward 10 to 12
suggestions for reducing gun violence
and no one suggestion would solve every
problem nor prevent every shooting the
suggestions are widespread and Broad it
includes eliminating any loophole that
allows the transfer of a gun without a
background check as an example
limiting clip capacity preventing people
under certain ages from buying certain
guns no one of and other things no one
solution no one change would be a
solution to every uh a shooting but
altogether they would make a difference
in total and isn't it still good to
reduce gun deaths even if you can't
prevent every gun deaths isn't it better
to prevent some particularly when you
can do so without placing any undue
burden on gun owners oh a background
check okay and without violating the
Second Amendment to the Constitution
seems worth doing to me and Brian has a
good addition which is well maybe it
wouldn't have prevented that one but it
might prevent the next one I like it
Garrett wrote in seemingly obsessed with
my party identification now as many of
you know I'm not a Democrat and what I
mean by that is it's just a binary thing
have I ever been registered as a
Democrat no have I ever donated to the
Democratic party no I'm not a Democrat
okay Garrett wrote in and says you are a
Democrat hi David can you just Embrace
that you're a Democrat I saw you once
slightly rant about how you're a Social
Democrat I don't even know what that
means I mean you can try to explain I
don't think you could so
Garrett's already confused
Democrat capital D Democrat which is
what he's talking about is a political
party
social democracy is a political ideology
it's not even one or the other these are
different categories of things now some
countries have a Social Democratic party
when I say I'm a Social Democrat I'm not
talking about an allegiance to a party
I'm saying my ideology is I'm a
progressive Social Democrat in terms of
party membership I'm not a member of the
democratic party two different things
okay
Garrett goes on it would be like well I
believe in a strong social safety net
free regulated Enterprise Bravo we all
do you seem like by all plain
definitions in U.S politics a Democrat
so just be one you're not special unless
you have some example as a
self-subscribed Social Democrat who
you're a huge supporter for who is that
who is the big politician you love who
is not a Democrat and if you say who it
is please tell me their policies are any
better than just a regular Democrat I'm
pretty sure you are just a Democrat
which is fine but live your life cheers
Garrett from New York City listen Gary I
don't know why you're so obsessed with
my party identification but I can't say
it any other way and if you're not
understanding I don't know what to do I
am not a member of the Democratic Party
the way I describe My Views is that I am
a progressive Social Democrat which is a
regulated form of capitalism
now everybody's policing my speech geez
um okay last one
hey instead of the December 24th
donation thingy
can't you sell David Pacman nfts I
seriously would pay 99 to help support
your great Channel but I want to see you
in an astronaut suit please I know
instead of doing the charity fundraiser
we did
I should have done what Trump did which
is I should have simply offered digital
trading cards of myself in all sorts of
strange and bizarre outfits I'm sure
they would have sold out in a day just
like Trump's uh but no we're not doing
that we did the charity fund Drive
and I think it was the right decision
we've got a great bonus show for you
today get instant access to the bonus
show by becoming a member at
joinpakman.com not only will you get
access to the bonus show you will also
get commercial free audio and video
streams of the show every day hours
before we publish them for everybody
else it's cheap it's quick it's easy
it's a great way heading into the new
year to support Independent Media that
you believe deserves support join
pacman.com you can use the coupon code
24 starts now and we will see you on
today's bonus show